[Musique]
imaginez que vous êtes en soirée ok avec
le co vide c'est dur d'imaginer imaginez
que vous êtes en soirée souvenir
lointain on vous demande ce que vous
voulez boire à ce moment là quel est
vôtre quelle est votre réponse qui
pensent que je prendre de l'eau en
premier ça dépend de l'heure mais en
vrai bien ouais c'est ça une bière si
cet hymne bière je pense que je prendrai
un soft ou glossy vraiment de soft j'ai
jamais vue de ma vie je consomme pas
d'alcool c'est pas quelque chose qui
m'intéresse donc je vais pas me mettre
spacek a rien de tout ça vachement
étonnante commence avec de l'eau
vraiment soif au hockey mais sinon c'est
un peuple à quoi va évidemment je
préférais forcément aux instances oda ou
un sirop que l'eau mais voilà il ya peu
de l'alcool ou de l'eau va forcément
géré par l'optima belle anaïs j'ai 21
ans et je suis là pour témoigner que
j'ai jamais vu une seule goutte d'alcool
de ma voix c'est comme ça j'ai jamais vu
d'alcool et je ramènerai correctement ma
bouteille parce que bah je sais pas
c'est qu'on pense aux autres je
m'appelle alan j'ai 23 ans je n'ai
jamais bu d'alcool car ça ne m'attire
pas du tout certain leurs objectifs à la
mois maintenant vu qu'on a qu'on dit
mais quand 16h du collège objectivité
[ __ ] de quelque chose dans l'ouverture
et s'est même déjà arrivé une fois
d'aller chercher des pizzas avec une
fille tu vois un peu plus loin dans la
ville d'à côté bref et du coup bas
j'étais parti il y en avait un il est
fait voilà bazille et où vont ils faire
goûter l'alcool et on met tout dedans
sont vertes choix et ma meilleure pote
de base joue à deux et non depuis lâché
pour la secoue la cdc pour andy ont mis
un fond de votre lot je ne sais quoi et
moi du coup mais je n'avais pas su soit
là j'ai reçu une autre soirée après
quand on fait un jamais je fais pas je
n'ai jamais eu à la colle et le mec qui
ne s'en fassent ce droit les yeux bat
non c'est faux badges batch connais ma
vie de choix il me fait banon parce que
de fonds amiante rupture et sur la
première action je me suis senti
vraiment genre salid choix non mais je
suis allé je le refais re visionner ma
consentants avoir complètement et du
coup je me suis cru dans la salle de
bain pour 15,8 en procédant genre t'es
j'avais pas m'arrêter c'était
systématique je me sentais vraiment
salies et travailler en temps ça lui
arrive c'est de prendre une canette et
d'ouvrir toi même problème mais en
fonction du type de ce soir et c'est moi
je sais que mourir je vais finir est
toujours et austin entre le cacherais
mais chaque fois je songe et place un
coup il sera derrière la cuisse réserve
et c'est moi de me rappeler où il est
chaud pas très sympa
ouais c'est pas super prémédité ce
budget n'est que ma mère m'a toujours
dit que si jamais même quand j'étais
petit j'étais enfin que la question se
posait pas elle m'a toujours dit tu ne
dis jamais ton verre des yeux avant même
que les mal pour quelqu'un qui soit
d'alcool même pour calculer la base
aussi ne pas boire de l'alcool égal ne
pas faire la fête
moi je trouve ça limite triste sort que
tu peux pas faire la fête sans alcool
parce que entre guillemets ça veut dire
que tu peux pas t'amuser avec tes amis
dans leur état normal tu es obligé de
dépendre de quelque chose d'autre pour
pouvoir t'amuser fin je trouve ça super
tresse en fait mais en tant que
personnes qui boivent beaucoup d'alcool
je suis aussi tout à fait d'accord qu'on
peut faire la fête en cendres de
l'alcool je m'appelle adèle j'ai 25 ans
je bois de l'alcool très régulièrement
surtout depuis les derniers confinement
quand je vais en boîte par exemple il
m'arrive de rester jusqu'à 6 heures en
dansant sans avoir bu une seule goutte
d'alcool
et c'est s'aider super soirée c'est donc
en fait qu'est ce que tu dis est en fait
la bonne humeur est communicative
t'es pas obligé à chaque fois de boire
même que ce soit envers je m'appelle
laurie j'ai 22 ans je bois
occasionnellement mais toutes les
occasions sont bonnes pour moi moi si tu
as besoin de boire dans une soirée s'est
dit mauvais signe en fait fin finalement
donné que les personnes avec qui tu es
tu t'amuses pas tant que ça à quoi vous
mesdames l'alcool pour le goût fin moi
je sais que si je bois de l'alcool c'est
pour le goût parfois pour ce sentiment
d'ivresse dont tu parlais et parfois
l'alcool c'est juste aussi du plaisir
un jour où il y aura deux il y aura une
boisson qui aura le même goût que
l'alcool mais sans alcool
tu vas boire avec le même plaisir du
coup n'ont pas ce que tu recherches les
faits aussi bien le tir charme c'est
pour ça qu'on a mal apprécié les effets
de l'ivresse tu vois je m'appelle adrien
j'ai 21 ans je travaille dans les bars
comme serveur à rennes et en bon breton
j'aime beaucoup faire la fête donc je
consomme pas mal d'alcool fonctionnement
aussi résonner modéré j'ai même si tu te
prends une grosse cabane tu vas tu as le
droit aussi de prendre du plaisir à
faire une grosse soirée comme ça où tu
un peu fait n'importe quoi
il s'est passé plein de petites
anecdotes tu vois et c'est pas parce que
tu as été un peu trop lointain repoussé
ses limites que forcément il ya un
énorme souci de consommation d'alcool ou
que tu as besoin de ça pour passer une
bonne soirée et du coup vous êtes aussi
chaud qui on propose une soirée sans
alcool qu'une soirée col où il ya quand
même
non non pas en tant que service de
soirée différente en voilà disparaît du
bcd soirée
il reste en mémoire d'une façon ou d'une
autre qu'il y ait d'alcool au gafi ouais
non mais clairement et puis ma mémoire
et la colle pas rose en simple j'ai 22
ans et avant je buvais beaucoup d'alcool
est maintenant quasiment plus tu as
vraiment ce truc de enfin boire de
l'alcool s'est pas automatiquement
synonyme de faire la fête mais admettons
que vous avez le choix entre deux
soirées le même jour avec les mêmes gens
mais alcool ou pas alcool
instinctivement si c'est les mêmes
soirées et même genre moi je moi
j'aurais tendance à fuir de l'avant et
si j'aurais tendance à dire effet le
champomy mais cinq minutes sachant
sachant aussi qu'on a des groupes d'amis
fin tout cas quand on prends ma part je
sors beaucoup donc forcément tous mes
amis autour de moi proches sont des gens
aussi qui sont très flatteurs donc
logiquement en fait ça va être le même
type de soirées qui se reproduit un peu
partout même si c'est dans des endroits
différents
il ya quelques personnes qui change
c'est un modèle de souris qui se répète
un schéma coin donc pour vous et quand
même un peu plus quoi ya de l'alcool à
une soirée très souvent de l'alcool ou
non c'était pas un plus c'est pas une
piste mais en vrai avec le co vide et je
suis totalement d'accord
maintenant vu qu'on a moins besoin de
sortir et que tu peux plus sortir comme
avant on va pas se mentir c'est plus
sympa d'avoir une soirée où la pression
aussi du quotidien qui fait que beaucoup
de gens cherchent à évacuer
l'alcool reste un moyen de décompresser
que les gens utilisent après à tort ou à
raison je ne sais pas mais en tout cas
enfin beaucoup de gens s'en servent
comme ça et forcément dans un contexte
de crise sanitaire hyper angoissant bas
la consommation d'alcool augmente tout
règlement vainement et le besoin de
faire la fête tout le temps on va
peut-être voir plus souvent et est ce
que ça ne vient pas dangereux justement
parce que tu bois souvent tu t'en lisent
dans quelque chose qui devient une
habitude et surtout rendre compte est
déjà dedans
est ce que par exemple jour au lendemain
si je te dis tu peux tu arrêtes l'alcool
tu peux le faire
oui oui oui j'ai déjà fais tu as déjà
faire moi sur le corps mais souvent
c'est ce que suis intérieur la pression
sociale
quant à des potes qui boivent c'est sous
moi je te dise est synonyme de fête
donc c'est vrai que si demain je vais en
soirée que je bois du coca à moins que
je sois malade est bizarre est-ce que du
coup ne trouve pas que c'est pas
absolument toxiques comme vision des
choses sur apps jack tu ne bois pas
d'alcool genre ce n'est pas normal ça va
être étonnant fait si je bois pas je
vais pas du tout est exclu et tout mais
ça et que ça va être étonnant c'est
peut-être aussi parce qu'ils la
connaissent et qu'ils savent que si
c'est bien intentionnés jazy a passé
bien intentionné mais c'est plutôt je
sais pas l'habitude si je suis un peu la
première ouvrir une bouteille à dire
17h30 lors de la petite
regardez là c'est pourquoi c'est l'heure
de l'apéro donc en vrai c'est plus aux
quotas ou mallory tu penses pas l'apéro
moi j'ai du mal à comprendre et à croire
les agents qu'ils disent je peux faire
un mois sans jamais l'avoir fait et ba
j'ai une anecdote là-dessus genre après
le premier confinement j'ai beaucoup
beaucoup fait la fête parce que je tiens
j'avais très envie d'écrire
ouais c'était vraiment venir je sortais
genre 5 à 6 jours par semaine
c'est pratiquement tout le temps en fait
c'étaient des bonnes soeurs échos et du
coup bah j'ai déjà j'ai vu des effets
sur mon corps assez rapidement donc
quand j'étais obligé de faire des
journées de pause temps en temps parce
que sinon ça va pas du tout mais mais
après ça ça m'est arrivé aussi dans des
moments où je dis bon stock
j'ai bien fait le malin pendant un mois
et demi deux mois là mais il faut que je
me pose et du coup de ne pas consommer
d'alcool pendant une semaine voire deux
semaines alors que j'avais consommé
quotidiennement ou presque avec des
quantités pas du tout raisonnable avant
et pas ressentir de man que pendant une
semaine ou deux sans aucun problème tu
vois pas de stress pas de faim pète
manque en fait quand je suis dit quand
tu perds mes premiers crus nantais
beaucoup sortir et où il fait pareil je
pense non mais une frustration
enfin en ce moment à le calmer mais
pareil est pas bon j'y prends juste ça
jusque très tard dans l'année parce
qu'après il y avait des vacances
du coup c'était pourquoi cette envie de
se mettre autant une caisse ouais c'est
l'euphorie
ouais l'emprunt feront entendre il faut
hausser les envies de salé du coup c'est
vous pensez vous que sans alcool vous
n'arrivez pas à arriver dans ce
sentiment d'euphorie pas autant à autant
tu peux aller loin et pas autant ça
c'est sûr parce que quand habitude de
boire de l'alcool est assez
régulièrement c'est moins facile de
débloquer ce truc là parce que l'alcool
trois bières donc en fait c'est un
sentiment de légèreté que qu'on peut
atteindre sans alcool mais qui quelques
facilite la grosse un raccourci quoi
ouais c'est vrai ça pour les non buveurs
est-ce que vous avez l'impression est
parfois exclus de soirée parce que vous
ne buvez pas d'alcool
c'est sûr parce que mes même pas
volontairement pour les autres c'est une
ambiance qui se créent monde et sous les
gens quand ils vont discuter entre eux
quand ils voient de bourret qu'en
extérieur à ça tu comprends rien bah on
voit qu'il ya pas trop de sens oui fm
discussion avec lui vide quand et sobre
compliqué quoi moi j'ai toujours eu le
sentiment d'être exclu aussi dans toutes
les soirées collège lycée mais en fait
ça ça c'est en effet boule de neige
c'est à dire que première soirée les
gens se rendent compte que tu bois pas
du coup bas la deuxième soirée ils vont
pas d'invités et vu que c'était pas là
la soirée d'avant ma la troisième foire
ils vont pas être invité et en fait
voilà comme tu n'es pas au soir et on
n'invite pas et ça fait vraiment en
effet boule de neige quoi c'est vrai que
quand on est jeune il ya vraiment une
pression sociale sur l'alcool qui est
qui est très forte
c'est une évidence c'est censé être une
évidence en fait c'est ah bon tu vois
pas mais il c'est bizarre non mais
pourquoi qu'est ce qui t'arrive tu es
normal
vous n'êtes pas dans la norme c'est ça
et pareil que j'entends toujours de
faire un coming out sur huit ans waits
et lui lance avec un cobaye fait la
taille whisky-coca non jusqu'au cas à
l'alcool dans une boîte et dans ce genre
de soirée au site sur ma chique des
sceaux je n'ai pas été invitée parce que
ces soirées beuveries et qui m'invitait
pas de choix juste par rapport à ça
parce que a et il va être drôle ou alors
pensé à moi j'ai pas besoin de ça pour
m'amuser et des fois les gens il a même
qui me correspond à 60 ans que je suis
bourré tellement je suis dans l'ambiance
je faire plus de conneries que ceux qui
sont bourrés de la bonne humeur c'est
communicatif c'est complètement ça tu
vois même des fois des plus jeunes que
moi tu vois passer dans cinq ans chez
voix ils sont où son état et si t'étais
pas là pour faire un cadeau ils
s'arrêtent très mal tourner tu dis un
moment il ya aussi un souci est quoi
vous avez plus 15 ans quoi ça m'a
carrément arrêt de mentir et de dire
qu'en fait je ne fais pas d'alcool parce
que je prenais des médicaments à côté
qui était pas compatibles ou quoi proulx
pas qu'on me dise ouais non mais c'est
juste que tu sais pas tu amusé ou quoi
je me donnais une excuse m'inventer des
excuses ça n'est pas arrivé très souvent
mais ça m'est arrivé
et ouais plus rochus et ultra triste en
fait je m'en veux un peu d'avoir fait ça
mais c'est fou mais c'est sûr que vous
soyez en train de dire c'est ce que moi
par exemple j'avais des anciennes
copines qui buvaient pas du tout pour
l'anecdote j'étais en espagne et pas
très longtemps avec des copines
l'avant-dernier soir on s'est mis une
caisse dans les règles de l'art et
j'étais dans un état lamentable
j'espère que ma mère de l'argent à cette
vidéo oui j'ai une copine qui du coup
s'est occupé de moi mais et moi je lui
disais en étant complètement ivre je
suis désolé vraiment vraiment excuses
mans et tout parce que je sais que ça
doit être chiant me gérer tout le monde
on a débriefé elle m'a dit mais non mais
moi je m'en fiche
enfin elle m'a dit moi ça me dérange pas
tu étais pas non plus incontrôlable avec
le style était bas tant pis on devra
mener jusqu'à la maison et ya pas de
problème mais c'est pas tous les soirs
c'est pas récurrents
et y'a intérêt comme je suis d'accord
avec toi et un peu ce truc-là de quand
tu bois pas tu t'occupes avait des
autres mais après c'est pas obligatoire
parce que souvent c'est souvent les gens
mêmes qui ont bu qui s'occupe des gens
qui ont encore plus mieux moi j'ai déjà
fait des soirées avec des gens qui ne
buvaient pas forcément j'adapte un petit
peu ma consommation aussi j'avais enfin
je fais en sorte que je sois pas la
grosse relou complètement bourré profite
à personne qui boit pas dans la soirée
en fait ça va déculpabiliser les autres
de dire ah ben je devais conduire mais
vu que toi tu bois pas je vais pouvoir
boire comme ça c'est bon tranquille
après moi ça m'arrive même pas parce que
j'ai pas dormi mais toi tu disais que ça
tu es tu arrivé d'être invité pour être
un peu le témoin j'ai tout à fait des
fois où je t'ai toujours le technicien
j'étais juste là pour faire la potiche
quand vous avez des expériences de
soirée ainsi ques vraiment pas des noms
mais moi j'ai pas vécu comme vous parce
que j'ai bu de l'alcool mais bon on n'a
jamais vu du tout ouais moi moi j'ai bu
de l'alcool donc mais je pense qu'il ya
peut-être aussi en crème au niveau 2 de
vos amis qui vous invite aussi d'être
basque et moralement parce que moi non
mais moi maintenant je vais tout début
quand que les personnes j'étais en école
d'ingénieur enfin vaut mieux boire lors
avoir fort mais mais quand on va en
soirée bon jeu buvait de l'alcool j'ai
été intégré et là maintenant je vais en
soirée je suis intégré aussi maintenant
que je vois pu enfin que je pourrais
très peu y'a pas de problème c'est plus
de manière indirecte c'est la soirée qui
fait que quand je parle surtout de julie
c'est parce que c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui j'ai plus de problème
avec ça oui mais au lycée au collège ou
au lycée on faisait des soirées il y
avait ont demandé à ceux qui buvaient
pas d'alcool
ce qu'ils voulaient voir c'était pas non
plus eux qui ramenait tout le monde
enfin c'est pas ça dépend aussi du
milieu de terrain jimmy diaz moi je vis
dans une cambrousse tous les fans soirée
c'était une personne s'asseoir et de
fonte initié chez au tueur du coup tu es
aussi plein de gens qui étaient extraits
à ton groupe mais tu avais pas le choix
parce que pour pouvoir organiser une
soirée folle et qui a un minimum de
monde quoi parce que souvent ces terres
et les parents sans week end on prend la
maison battu voitures peuvent en soirée
trois dorée barack tu amènes plein de
gens et d'autres genres amène d'autres
gens ce qui sait aussi qu'il y avait cet
environnement aussi différent tu vois je
rebondis là dessus du coup ce que j'ai
fait aussi et seraient dans la
cambrousse comme tu dis avant que j'ai
pas toujours habiter en ville
j'habite en ville que depuis très peu de
temps en soi et les soirées que je vous
avais campagne rumba c'est vrai qu'en
soi il n'ya pas le même consommé
dans lequel elle est différente déjà les
gens boivent le week-end parce que la
semaine y travaillent il ya le côté
c'est très énorme et en général les
hommes d'un côté les femmes de l'autre
il n'y a pas les mêmes consommation chez
les messieurs les meufs fermer ta un
côté jeu retrait on se lâche on s'éclate
et il faut consommer beaucoup s'est mis
en valeur la quantité d'alcool que tu
bois est clairement mise en valeur et
les gens keating l'alcool ceux qui
tiennent mal l'alcool cela conduit à des
comportements de gamins et du coup quand
tu vois pas tu en arrives à faire la
garderie tueur et c'est ridicule pour
terminer on a un témoignage qu'on
voudrait vous partagez qu'on va vous
faire écouter et juste après on va
pouvoir en discuter ce un témoignage
audio qu'on vous faire écouter
maintenant bonjour je me présente je
m'appelle christophe j'ai 46 ans
peut-être j'ai bu pendant 20 ans donc je
vais lui de façon régulière c'est à dire
tous les jours je buvais une bouteille
de rhum plus des bières fortes de l'a86
en général un le matin au réveil on est
mal on transpire on tremble on ne vous
pourrez pas vous expliquer tellement on
est mal on en décomposition on est
fragile ans non mais vraiment très très
très mal et la seule chose qui me
soigner ce mal c'était de bain consommer
dès le matin au réveil
pendant deux ans je travaillais pas je
m'embêtais je recevais des factures mais
je mettais tout côté moi la seule chose
qui m'importait c'était d'aller chercher
de l'alcool à côté de chez moi le plus
rapidement possible je n'arrivais au
magasin j'étais j'irai marcher trois
minutes j'étais en transe j'avais des
grosses gouttes qui collecte partout je
tremblais je n'étais pas bien j'avais la
tête qui tournait à 20 h
voilà il ça tous les jours au réveil je
me servais montvert et dès que j'avais
vu mes premières gorgées
c'est comme si tout redevenait normale
comme si mon corps revivent y avait que
l'alcool qu'ils pouvaient faire revivre
la machine lors je vous passe aussi le
fait de broyer du noir de se renfermer
pas des envies mais pensé au suicide
d'une fois parce que je la porterai rien
à personne ni à moi même c'est la perte
de confiance et la perte de repères
socialement
c'était le néant me suis retrouvé chez
moi pendant deux ans enfermée à être sur
l'ordinateur et à picoler voilà avoir
personne ne connaître personne ma
famille qui s'éloignait moi qui mets le
nez de ma famille bref vous détruit on
se détruiront détruit toute notre vie
avec ça tout ce qu'on a construit on les
construit et le problème c'est que même
maintenant que j'en que j'en sois sorti
j'ai des séquelles ça fait bientôt trois
ans que je suis abstinent je peux vous
affirmer que je n'ai jamais été aussi
bien que depuis que j'ai arrêté
est-ce que réagir à ce à ce témoignage
qu'on a qu'on a reçu c'est bien aussi
du coup on entend ce genre de témoignage
pour bien rappeler que en fait l'alcool
quoi qu'on puisse en penser que ce soit
tolérant société ça reste une drogue en
fait c'est une drogue légale
après faut toujours en avoir conscience
en fait soit on est à l'aise avec le
fait de consommer une drogue
occasionnellement
soit on ne l'est pas du tout est donc
dans ce cas là comme vous on peut
refuser mais il faut jamais oublier que
c'est une drogue c'est tout répond non
le rappelle pas assez aussi jeu
totalement d'accord il devrait y avoir
beaucoup plus de prévention là dessus en
fait totalement mais je sais pas si pour
vous la six a fait la même chose que
pour moi mais d'entendre ce témoignage
moi ça m'a fait un vieux coup de rappel
à l'ordre
enfin je me sens un peu mal après avoir
entendu tout ça on en a presque rigoler
on en a on en a parlé de manière très
légère on a parlé de plaisir on a parlé
de fait on a parlé de moments joyeux et
tout
et puis en fait mais même moi quand je
bois j'en oublie que ça un vrai impact
sur ma santé sur la façon dont mon corps
il va réagir n'est d'accord et le mans
matin et là dessus je suis assez
d'accord sur son témoignage dans une
moindre mesure parce que je ne bois pas
autant que lui et puis pas tous les
jours mais c'est vrai que quand tu
passes une soirée où tu as beaucoup eu
le lendemain on attend ton corps il a du
mal à s'en remettre et est de plus en
plus et plus tu vieillis et nous voit
tout le temps des gens qui disent le
lendemain matin plus jamais et puis hop
le week-end d'après certaines études
ailleurs on utilise la phrase tu soignes
le mal par le mal c'est clermont pour
l'alcool s'est trouvé en plus c'est
tellement créativement la bière que tu
bois le lendemain si tu repars en soirée
le lendemain elle enlève complètement
toutes les sous les effects a eu comme
un clin d'oeil on reporte donc
évidemment je vais rebondir sur le
témoignage est dit quelque chose
enfin c'est très intéressant c'est qu'en
fait vous pouvez boire régulièrement
sans avoir de problèmes d'alcoolisme
un jour tu as une emmerde un jour tu as
un problème qui s'est réfugié dans je
peux est enfermé dedans et je mens tu
peut basculer et c'est ça qui est
dangereux c'est qu'en fait tu crées une
situation où tu est enlisé dans une
consommation d'alcool l'esa et un jour
parce qu'il ya un problème parce qu'il
ya une emmerde tu tombe dedans et tu va
m'acheter d'accord sur le truc du déclic
où il ya un moment en fait c'est un
moment de basculement moi je trouve que
le coc vide pour la partie des étudiants
moi j'ai plein de potes à moi pour ceux
qui habitent seuls pas spécialement mais
d'autres potes on s'est réfugié dans
l'alcool y avait un peu il ya un peu ce
truc de bascule ou genre c'est vrai que
notre consommation d'alcool mon jour
qu'elle a beaucoup plus grande dit le
confinement ça a été terrible
depuis le salon mais ça nous a ruiné et
tu vois pas ou presque il disait moi ça
m'a touché parce que je connais des
personnes en ce que dans cinq ans et
feront son témoignage commission
le coc vide en fait et le fait d'être
vraiment tout le temps isolés tout le
temps enfermé chez soi ça poussait
énormément de jeunes vers l'alcool
on sent quand même que il ya une
habitude ancrée et parfois la différence
entre boire un verre et devenir un pâle
coliques elle est quand même très fines
sont beaucoup plus ouverts que j'aurais
pu l'imaginer c'était des choses dont
j'étais pas consciente et qui me
m'interroge moi même sur les fois où
j'ai pu avoir des comportements aussi
aux toxiques envers des personnes qui ne
font pas la même consommation que moi